handsome jack is buying a pony made of
diamonds the price of the pony is P
dollars and Jack also has to pay a 25%
Diamond Pony tax match the expressions
to their meaning for handsome Jack and
they say multiple expressions may fit in
the same may fit the same description
alright so in this bucket we have the
price of the diamond pony before tax
well they already tell us that the price
of the diamond Pony is P dollars so
that's P right over here now over here
they say the amount of tax handsome Jack
pays well he pays a 25 percent diamond
pony tax so whatever the price is he's
going to pay 25 percent of that or
another way of thinking about he's going
to pay 25 percent is the same thing as
0.25 so 0.25 times P is the amount of
tax he's going to pay on this Diamond
pony
now they say handsome Jack's total bill
for the diamond pony well he's going to
pay P for the pony plus 0.25 P in taxes
so that is this one right over here P
for the pony plus 0.25 P for the taxes
so that's that one over there but if we
look at this you could view this
literally as 1p plus 0.25 peas well
that's the same thing as 1.25 P so
that's the same thing as this right over
here so it's 1.25 P and these other
three don't seem to fit in any of these
categories so I'm going to put it into
the not use we're required to categorize
everything so let me put this in the not
used just falling off the screen I
realize let me put this in the not used
and then let me put this in the not used
let's check our answer
we got it right